bonjour à tous aujourd'hui j'aimerais
vous parler de john nash qui est un des
plus grands mathématiciens du 20e siècle
il est aussi un personnage peut-être un
peu connus du grand public à travers
deux films un homme d'exception où il
est incarné par russell crowe et ce film
est en fait basé sur la biographie de la
vie de john nash par sylviane hasard
aujourd'hui ce que je vais vous dire est
essentiellement basé sur ce livre donc
jeanne h sa contribution en tout cas
pour laquelle il est le plus connu
c'est sa contribution à la théorie des
jeux voire l'invention de cette théorie
de jeu alors techniquement faut savoir
que le concept de théorie dite théorie
des jeux existent depuis 1928 il a été
inventée par john von neumann tonnes von
neumann qui était moment où nash était
en thèse à princeton von neumann était
le patron de princeton lyman c'est un
personnage extrêmement important dans
l'histoire des mathématiques et
notamment des mathématiques appliquées
parce que il me semble en tout cas que
bonne mais je suis tout simplement
inventé
grosse grosse partie des mathématiques
appliquées aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
que quand je me balade dans des bureaux
dans des labos de mathématiques
appliquées
je vois les petits-fils de vannes a man
essayer d'étendre les théorique que von
neumann avait avait suggéré que ce soit
un optimisation en statistiques en
mécanique quantique en théorie ergodique
énormément de choses sont le fruit des
idées de von neumann qui ont ensuite été
étendue par par ses étudiants à ses
successeurs
bref ça pour insister sur le fait que
neumann était vraiment un espèce de dieu
lorsqu'il était professeur à princeton
l'un des deux dieux d'ailleurs de
princeton puisque l'autre dieu était un
certain albert einstein et en gros enfin
les deux dirigées institute of advanced
study là bas et donc voix de manu
n'écrit ce premier article comme une 128
sur tora minimax en théorie des jeux et
puis il a surtout écrit en 1944 avec
oscar morgenstern un bouquin qui
s'appelle series of games sénégal avec
bo qui est parlé du premier gros bouquin
de microéconomie donc je vais pas
rentrer trop dans les détails mais en
gros il présente dans ce bouquin une
première vision de comment étudier les
interactions humaines les théories des
contrats ou pourquoi est ce que les gens
font ce qu'ils font pourquoi est ce que
c'était vraiment pas mal en temps de
guerre pourquoi est ce que les
etats-unis doivent faire la guerre ou ne
pas faire la guerre contre tel ou tel
pays
l'urss notamment cette théorie ce
qu'elle fait c'est qu'elle étudie donc
des jeux où il ya que deux joueurs et ce
nul c'est à dire que tout ce que l'un
gagne l'autre le père est un exemple de
tels jeux c'est le tic tac toe ou le
pierre feuille ciseaux le jeu d'échecs
le jeu de go tous ces jeux où il ya 2
voir et à la fin il y a
un vainqueur et un perdant ou un match
nul
puis peut avoir un gagnant qui gagnent
plus qui viennent deux points si le
gagnant gagne deux points c'est que
perdre on va perdre de points vous voyez
l'idée paf à cette époque là donc le
dieu des mathématiques appliquées von
neumann travaille pas mal sur la théorie
des jeux et du coup un âge se dit que
s'il pouvait écrire un truc sur la
théorie des jeux et bien il deviendrait
respecter devant neufmanil de course à
avoir la gloire et tout ça est l'une des
premières grandes inventions de de john
nash qui a permis de se faire remarquer
à princeton
c'est d'inventer un un jeu s'appelle le
jeu de sexe dont big mat en parle dans
une de ces vidéos est en fait ce jet de
hex est devenu extrêmement populaire par
la suite à princeton où les professeurs
et jouets le midi un fjord pas trop dans
les détails dans le sud de ce veut juste
indiqué que nash se faire opérer avec ce
jeu à princeton et du coup ils
commencent à gagner un petit peu
d'importance et puis après en 1948-49 il
s'aperçoit que il ya des jeux où il n'y
a pas de joueur puis à des jeux il n'y a
pas de somme nulle il a peut-être en
tête à ce moment là l'idée selon
laquelle quand on décide de faire la
guerre lorsque deux pays se décide de
faire la guerre va y avoir un gagnant et
un perdant mais le perdant peut perdre
plus que ce que l'autre gagne dans un
mois si on compare ça à une situation de
paix donc lorsque ont choisi de faire la
guerre ou la paix n'est pas dans une
situation à somme nulle puisque ce que
parce qu'une fois qu'on a décidé de
faire la guerre on sait que globalement
on va tous perd donc du coup il ya
quelque chose qui est perdu par tout le
monde
donc ça c'est juste répartition plus
précises parce qu'on appelle le dilemme
du prisonnier alors le dilemme du
prisonnier
imaginons que il ya deux prisonniers qui
se font arrêter pour un petit délit un
truc pas trop grave pour lequel il
risque un mois de prison la police va
voir ensuite chacun des deux
prisonnier et supposons que en situation
où la police suspecte fortement les deux
en fait d'avoir commis un crime
il ya deux ou trois ans assez grave
vraiment grave pour lequel il risque 10
ans de prison club et la police pense
qu'ils ont faim ils allaient coopérer
pour faire ça creuse du coup la police
d'avoir chacune chacun des prisonniers
séparément et demande à chacun des
prisonniers de balancer l'autre pour la
police a dit à chacun des prisonniers
si tu me balance l'autre est d'avoir un
mois de prison je vais te devais te
laisser partir
par contre l'impact a balancé l'autre
l'autre se prend dix ans de prison
et puis dans le cas où les deux se
balancent mutuellement on va dire qu'ils
ont tous les deux a vu huit ans de
prison au lieu de 10 ans donc là si on
laissait d'ailleurs fléchir
individuellement si on s'imagine être
l'un des prisonniers
on se dit que bon bah si l'autre ne
balance pas s'il veut si moi je balance
alors je veux pas sans me sont passées
par la prison alors que si je le balance
pas je vais aller en prison et du coup
si le balance pas j'ai intérêt à le
balancer d'accord non qu'est ce qui se
passe il me balance le ballon ce que je
le balance part je me prends dix ans de
prison
et si le balancer que je le balance on a
tous les deux à huit ans de prison donc
j'ai je fais moins de prison si je le
balance
même dans le cas où 8me valence dans
tous les cas en fait j'ai intérêt à le
balancer ça c'est ce qu'on appelle le
dilemme du prisonnier et c'est un
dilemme dans le sens où si chacun suit
son incitatif individuel les deux
prisonniers vont soit trouvé avec huit
ans de prison alors que si avant d'être
interrogé par la police il avait passé
un pacte et avait suivi ce patte de ne
pas se sent trop balancé du coup il y
aurait eu chacun un mois de prison donc
là la coopération et apporte un résultat
ici bien meilleur que les incitatifs
individuelle et ce à la théorie devant
norman n'est pas capable de le décrire
et c'est en cinq que là je pense que sa
nouvelle théorie cette théorie plus
générale des jeux
sont d'ailleurs pas forcément à deux
joueurs pour le coup et qui sont aussi
capables de décrire ces phénomènes de
possibles coopérations et beaucoup plus
général est beaucoup plus puissante que
la théorie de bonnes manières en
pratique elle est vraiment beaucoup plus
puisque dans beaucoup de cas pratiques
c'est pas je gagne tu perds on peut
avoir des situations de
'gagnant-gagnant' ou des situations
perdante perdante donc nash est tout
fier de son observation il écrit sa
thèse par rapport à ça elle teste de
fait que 27 pages ce qui est assez
incroyablement cours pour une thèse et
surtout le plus surprenant avec sept as
et qu'il n'y a que deux situations dont
une citation c'est un papier qui l'écrit
lui-même non car en fait dans cette
thèse this is it unique mot lui-même et
von neumann
c'est un truc qui clairement ne
passerait plus du tout aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui qu'on écrit une thèse vous
même un article de recherche au moins
enfin l'article de recharge pour au
moins quinze vingts citations et pour
une thèse faut moins 50 voire 100
citation aujourd'hui une course après
les citations et une ac ne fait pas que
ça avec cette théorie il surtout ils
comptent aller voir von neumann et gagné
le respect
du dieu de princeton du coup il prend
rendez-vous gbagbo neumann est déjà ça
c'est fou parce que lé pas que von
lohmann est vraiment un dieu et même les
professeurs hésitent à le déranger faut
vraiment que ça soit un truc important
pour avoir dérogé von neumann alors d'un
étudiant mais c'est ce que c'est quand
même fou c'est très très osées quoi mais
bon ça n'empêche pas nash de prendre ce
rendez vous il vient parler donc il va
parler à vos neumann et je vais deviner
que pendant cette réunion
nash a été un peu arrogant ou à dix les
truies qui ne plaisait pas à von neumann
toujours est il que selon la légende une
fois que nash a défini ses explications
ou même peut-être avant vanneman le
coupé lui dis faites ce trivial de ce
que tu as fait c'est juste en interne du
préfixe ce qui est vrai ce qui est tout
à fait vrai dans le sens où d'un point
de vue mathématique en fête pour toute
la théorie de nash facile c'est pas
simple c'est pas ultra simple mais c'est
pas très compliqué non plus passer
passer par un résultat de mathématiques
tour de génie au niveau mathématique
c'est plus un tour désigné au niveau de
la modélisation et de la théorique mais
ça ça n'a pas du tout impressionné en
tout cas bonne nomades
peut-être qu'il a sous-estimé enfin il
me semble quand même qu'il a sous-estimé
l'importance qu'aurait cette théorie ce
que cette théorie de nash lui fera
remporter le prix nobel mais bien bien
bien plus tard il finit ses années à
princeton du coup avec très belle thèse
mais pas de résultat mathématique
incroyable qui en tout cas il ne gagne
pas le respect de toute la communauté
mathématique comme ils l'auraient espéré
ont toujours est il qu'il se fait
engager ensuite après sa thèse
par la rand corporation donc rendre
c'est pour bisevac and development
donc c'est un institut de recherches kof
beaucoup de mathématiciens qui
travaillent sur des problèmes liés
souvent des projets gouvernementaux
donc pendant cette période nash écrit
une lettre à la msa qui est vraiment
vraiment remarquable mais pas du tout
remarqué en tout cas c'est confidentiel
pendant longtemps et on s'était
découvert seulement récemment en gros
dans ce papier à nashua vient à la
conclusion que la cryptographie
le fait de pouvoir faire des systèmes
cryptographiques efficace ou pas va
dépendre de notre capacité à résoudre
des problèmes rapidement ou pas ça peut
pas ta c'est bizarre comme ça mais en
fait ça décrit subtilement un des
problème le plus important aujourd'hui
de l'informatique théorique et des
mathématiques qui est un problème qui
vaut un million de dollars par le clay
mathematics qui est qu'on appelle le
principe et versus mp je veux pas trop
entrer dans les détails mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'il fait cette
remarque mais des décennies deux
décennies avant que ce problème soit
révélée vraiment comme un problème
important par la communauté mathématique
informatique mais très propre que les
mecs de là est né ça n'est pas trop
compris tous les arguments en tout cas
de nage donc à la création ça se passe
assez bien mais un jour il se fait
arrêter par la police
pour relations homosexuelles et à
l'époque bas c'était très mal vu à
l'époque en angleterre il y avait le cas
turing ici l'on classe ce canal orne h
leucan est dans le cas de nash c'est
resté plus secret ils ont réussi à
couvrir un petit peu plus la faire mais
ils ont quand même dû forcer nash a
démissionné de leur incorporation à
cause de cette histoire de nos
sexualités nash débarque alors om haïti
où il devient chargé de cours et om
éthique ans avoir une relation avec
eleanor aux tailleurs qui est une
infirmière et finit même par avoir un
enfant avec elle mais il ne propose la
proposer à mon mariage
lennar s'est d'ailleurs elle voulait
absolument se marier avec nash mais n'en
avait pas le convaincre et la raison
pour laquelle nash je ne l'accepté pas
de se marier ou que ne jamais proposer
de se marier semble être qu'ils
trouvaient que il n'appartenait pas à la
même classe sociale porn h
elle est à nord n'était qu'une
infirmière alors que nash lui c'était
lui se penser comme une méga star des
mathématiques et du cui en fait il ne
reconnaîtra jamais publiquement l'enfant
qu'il a eu avec eleanor ce tailleur par
ailleurs lâché en fait assez déçu d'être
au et mendy parce que à l'époque le
métier était pas aussi reconnu qu'
aujourd'hui surtout en tout cas en
mathématiques et nash voulait aller à
harvard et powell m'a ici parce qu'il
pensait que harvard c'était beaucoup
plus classe beaucoup le plus à son pas
son niveau et du coup il fera ceci
explique peut-être un petit peu sa
condescendance et son arrogance envers
ses collègues du fmi team est donc ce
que son histoire un jour son collègue de
bureau embers warren lui fait la
remarque
si tu es si intelligent de san hp résout
pas le problème du plongeon de saison
métriques je vais pas raconter à nouveau
ce coquet la pointe du plongement
isométrique j'en ai déjà parlé dans
cette vidéo je vais quand même souligner
que nash est incroyablement arrogant par
rapport à ça puisque alors que c'est
enfin vraiment vraiment très très très
très difficile vieux de son temps etc
nash va s'amuser à annoncer à tout le
monde qu'il a déjà résolu alors qu'il
n'a même pas en fait commencé à
l'étudier et s'il faisait ça c'était
juste pour savoir si ce problème était
un problème vraiment important pour
lequel il serait reconnu qu'on vaut
prophète lequel s'il arrive à le
résoudre il serait reconnu pour comme
étant l'un des plus grands
mathématiciens de tous les temps et sans
doute que la raison pour laquelle il a
fait ça est lié remarque qu'il a vu de
bonnes vannes par rapport à sa thèse en
tout cas les gens ont l'air clairement
impressionné par son passé annonce du
coup il cherche vraiment à prouver ce
théorème est le plus fou c'est ce qu'il
y avait
et puis en plus la preuve qui fait très
très surprenant très très très très
intéressante et puis c'est comme un
poème ultra important de géométrie de
savoir qu'est ce que la géométrie est ce
que les géométries construite depuis
l'intérieur comme alary made est ce que
c'est la même que la géométrie vu comme
espèce de tissus donc un sou espace une
sous variété qu'on les appelle dans un
espace plus grand plat de la même façon
que lorsqu'on veut une feuille de papier
on voit un espace daudet à l'intérieur
d'un espace 3d et nash donc à voir il va
prouver que la réponse est oui on peut
toujours voir tout tout tout variétés
comme une sous variété dans un espace
plus grand
bref il appréciait énormément les gens
avec ses résultats cette fois là c'est
c'est on le reconnaît nash est un génie
et en particulier nierenberg un
chercheur
de new york university du club
institutes l'invite du coup à new york
pour pouvoir travailler sur un homme un
nouveau problème un point qui est
vraiment très très important qui a un
problème de sur les équations
différentielles donc techniquement ça un
truc sur les équations aux dérivées
partielles parabolique et non linéaire
bref un truc vraiment vraiment très
compliqué l'équation de vidalia vais
passer ce tour et les trucs super
compliqué et nash accepte s'il y va mais
ni embarquer un trail blanc déçu il est
incroyablement déçu du niveau de nash
parce que nash a l'air d'être un
débutant pose des questions complètement
stupide mais ça ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est un débutant qui
persévèrent et du coup va tous les jours
et il va dans le but redonner un bar il
propose quelques idées et pose des
questions c'est des questions tout débit
ni ringard se dit mais c'est pas
possible qu'on est en train de perdre du
temps ces mecs et pas du tout au niveau
rage à l'école et pourtant pourtant de
fur et à mesure mais mois après et moi
mois après mois les questions des neiges
de plus en plus intelligentes et de plus
en plus perspicaces et petit à petit on
sent que le match commence à avoir sa
propre intuition du problème il voit le
problème différemment de la manière dont
les autres voient le problème ils y
arrivent paru même plus et ça je pense
que c'est un trait assez intéressant de
la personnalité de nash mais plus
généralement de pas mal de
mathématiciens comme gros indique
poincaré qui qui qui préfère réfléchir
de même plutôt qu'à prendre un cours par
coeur et sait de redémontrer tout ce
qu'il ya de trouver par lui même tout le
contenu d'un cours de mode mais ça je
pense que c'est vrai avoir un truc qui
devrait être vraiment plus en syrie je
sais pas comment l'enseigner quoi je ne
sais pas non plus comment faire des
examens par rapport à ça mais là la
vraie joie mathématiques c'est vraiment
cette exploration de soi même et
d'essayer d'écrire tout seul le contenu
du cours
c'est là c'est là que c'est vraiment
intéressant les mathématiques quand
indique disait que livre de
mathématiques n'était pas fait pour être
plus mais pour être écrivain ça c'est un
peu exagéré parce que moi ces comptes
indique mais il ya quelque chose de très
intéressant derrière ça que je sais que
j'avais déjà parlé avec des amis dont un
ami économistes qui disait que c'était
horrible avait trop définition à
connaître en mathématiques mais en fait
il est techniquement il n'y a pas de de
trucs à apprendre par coeur normalement
mathématiques qu'il ya foyer quelques
principes de base à connaître par coeur
il faut connaître un petit peu quelques
règles de logique mais a priori toute
l'idée des mathématiques c'est de
construire des objets de construire par
semaine de construire des nouveaux
objets et puis assez de prouver ensuite
des relations entre ces objets mais de
tout tout est une histoire de
construction la plus élégante la plus
naturelle possible et en fait si on
impose le critère d'élégance et de
naturelle des mathématiques et bien
souvent on va être amené à réécrire ce
qui est déjà écrit dans les livres parce
que les mathématiques ce vol simple et
naturelle est en fait normalement si on
fait des mathématiques
on doit reproduire ce qui a déjà été
produit on doit marcher dans les pas des
géants de deux siècles précédents
et c'est le cas c'est exactement ce que
fait mme nash maintes reprises on vit de
la prends pas du tout secours je suis
pas du tout les chemins tracés
il trace sa propre voie et forcément sa
propre voie vu que c'est un gène ikke
c'est qui c'est un mathématicien de
première classe qui qui sans l'élégance
mathématiques il va souvent suivre il va
retracer les chemins qui ont déjà été
tracé avant lui mais parfois elle va
aussi créer des schémas qui nous avait
été tracé avant et c'est là que c'est
vraiment intéressant au niveau de la
recherche puisqu'il apporte ainsi des
nouveaux produits des nouveaux d'une
nouvelle voie d'exploration pour
comprendre vous pourrez accéder à
certains résultats mathématiques et en
tout cas c'est le cas pour les équations
aux dérivées partielles puisqu'au fur et
à mesure en essayant au plomb ces
questions qui vont qui sont pas normales
pour un théoricien des équations aux
dérivées partielles
il finit par aboutir à un résultat que
les experts de l'époque n'arrivait père
n'arrivait pas à trouver de même et du
coup donc vers 1956 57 vers 1956 match
devient petit à petit l'expert mondiale
des trade certaines équations aux
dérivées partielles en particulier il
réussit à résoudre le problème que
nierenberg lui a confiée et il le fait
de façon magistrale de cette façon
orchestral bon sens où il sait que le
premier très compliqué que ça va lui
prendre beaucoup de temps et qu'il a
besoin d' aide en particulier il sait
exactement quels sont les points qui qui
peuvent être décidées question un peu
c'est pareil quand ils sont pas
forcément au but
directement les coller aux équations
l'équation dit à mes parcelles qui
l'étudient et du coup il peut confier
ses morceaux à d'autres personnes et en
fait c'est ce qui va faire il va un
petit peu dire à gauche à droite à
certaines personnes de s'intéresser à
tel ou tel problème
et puis il va réunir des solutions de
tout le monde et ça va qu'on dise ça va
faire un tout tout va complètement
s'agencer parfaitement et ça ça va faire
la preuve finale qu'il cherchait pour
étudier son équations aux dérivées
partielles
donc c'est une preuve même magnifique
qu'il fait manque de bol à il l'obtient
c'est un an après à matin autres
mathématicien italien
donc il n'est pas le premier à approuver
le théorème concernant c'est équations
aux dérivées partielles et du coup il
n'a pas la gloire totale en tout cas
qu'il pense mériter
et ça c'est un truc assez récurrent fait
dans la vie de noces nash est quelqu'un
qui court énormément après la gloire des
succès est là ce qui vient de se prendre
c'est un petit peu un coup de poing dans
le ventre
en se rendant compte que la belle preuve
magistrale qu'il avait obtenues ne lui
apportera pas la gloire qu'il espérait
et ça ça va être suivi d'un deuxième
coup de poing qui va lui faire encore
tout le mal qui est l'attribution des
médailles fields les deux 1958
nash ne reçoit pas mais n'en finissent
en 1958 et ça il le prend très mal le
prend très mal et c'est vraiment dommage
qu'ils le prennent très mal parce que
nash n'a que 30 ans à l'époque et la
règle du et de la médaille fils et
jusqu'à 40 ans donc il est encore
largement le temps cours des quatre
prochaines années suivantes
tu as bossé comme il le comme une fête
puis en 62 c'est sûr qu'il a
paul quasiment sûr qu'il aura sa
médaille fields mais la chubu les avis
des 58 et il prend très mal le fait
qu'il ne l'a pas et il semblerait que
cela ait précipité une maladie génétique
dont il souffrira de pucerons qui
commence à souffrir à ce moment là être
dont il souffrira de plus en plus qui
est une schizophrénie
donc à la fin des années 50 et début des
années 60
nash à des épisodes de schizophrénie de
plus en plus graves
si bien que sa femme est à ce moment là
donc qualifié de l'art des avec qui il a
un enfant à ce moment là alicia donc
cette fois il est marié alicia doit
l'interné en tout cas fini par interné
dans un hôpital psychiatrique et la lnh
ça commence à être le début de l'enfer
où il va avoir des épisodes il va aller
bien pendant six mois puis après il va
devoir autres points il va se faire un
nouveau interné contre contre son gré
c'est la période de très difficile delà
de la vidéo ne veux même pas imaginer
donc il reçoit des traitements coup
d'insuline apparemment très très très
difficile et pas vraiment pas efficace
dans les années 60 un moment je sais pas
si quelqu'un doit attribuer sa
schizophrénie mais il décide à un moment
dans les années 60 de partir en europe
et de renoncer à sa citoyenneté
américaine
il va sûrement en france cécile de
rendre son passeport puis en suisse
mais les gens le raisonne à chaque fois
et puis à chaque fois fini par ne pas
pouvoir rendre son passeport il
rencontre aussi notamment gros syndicats
ce moment là avec qui il partage
beaucoup de convictions politiques et
interrompt ses convictions politiques
sont assez intéressants autant ces
histoires d'anti nationalisme parce que
beaucoup de beaucoup de charge de grands
un génie de l'époque ils peuvent
supprimer le concept de nationalisme de
nationalité même pas ce qu'ils
considèrent que la cause des première et
seconde guerres mondiales et de nombreux
conflits à travers le monde et ce côté
enfin ce nationalisme ambiant le fait
que les gens s'identifient un pays et
ils veulent défendre ce pays
parfois donc au péril de leur vie et
donc pendant toutes les années 60
nash va fréquemment devoir fréquenter
les hôpitaux psychiatriques
donc la schizophrénie de nash manifeste
notamment à travers des croyances
étrange
enfin me fait qu' il ya un empereur
pingouins qui domine les humains ou des
histoires de numérologie qu'il envoie
ses collègues mathématicien sur la
signification de certains nombres ou la
croyance que des aliens
c'est de communiquer la terre et que
nash est le seul qui soit suffisamment
intelligent pour pouvoir capter ce
message et du coup les aliens lui parle
directement
bref pas mal de trucs comme ça qu'ils
qui l'empêchent de se concentrer sur
quoi que ce soit intéressant
après les années 70 des années 70 on lui
donne accès à princeton à la
bibliothèque de queenstown passera pas
mal de temps dans la bibliothèque de
princeton mais avec certaines absences
si l'état leur fantôme les gens ne
peuvent pas l'aborder
il est distant est toujours étrange
il exige beaucoup de lettres qui n'ont
qu'un sens les années et les décennies
défilent dans les années soixante dix
années 80 les années 90 est ce assez
miraculeusement que début des années 90
nash commence à refaire surface petit à
petit il commence à écrire des lettres
qui ont de plus en plus de sens qui
commence à avoir parfois même vie
commence à créer ailleurs des
mathématiques qui ont qu'il retrouve une
certaine logique
puis voir une certaine rigueur et puis
il commence à pouvoir parler plus
facilement avec d'autres personnes
face à ces grâce à ce renouveau son nom
est proposée par le comité du prix nobel
et il recevra en 1994 le prix nobel pour
ses travaux de thèse que von neumann
pensée triviaux et nash
enfin après décennie de travaux acharnés
de très très grande qualité et 3 dessiné
des errements et de souffrance
schizophrénique nash obtient enfin la
règle la reconnaissance qu'il mérite
il devient alors
enfants d'abord un économiste reconnu
puis petit à petit un mathématicien
vraiment reconnu ses travaux sur les
équations aux dérivées partielles et sur
la géométrie et le point la métrique
gagne beaucoup sont salués par toute la
communauté et gagne énormément de
récompenses de prix grâce à ceux-ci et
nash comprend sa schizophrénie lutte
contre cette schizophrénie ou jour le
jour et réussit maintenant a enfin
réussi ensuite à vivre normalement il
n'y aura même pas enseigner à princeton
des cours de mathématiques qui cherchera
aussi à faire de la recherche
mathématique avec des travaux sur
tellement la relativité générale et sur
l'hypothèse de riemann nash est mort en
2015 suite d'un accident de voiture avec
sa femme ali shah il avait alors 86 ans
il a vécu une vie incroyablement
complexe c'est un homme d'exception